How can we draw in the style of Renaissance?
This is of course,
a very old drawing style.
And what you immediately notice is that there's
couple things they do different
and things they do very similar
to how we do things today.
And almost like they understood it more than.
Than we did today.
So one of the things is the head construction
is fairly different to how we do it now.
So they started ahead
like a very egg like shape
and you might say,
well, we still do that,
and to some degree, yes, we do,
but we do change it up a little bit
and we have a little bit more
structure in how we approach that.
So they didn't have Loomis back in the day
to help them out,
so they usually started with an X shape
and then of course
also used lots of reference to help them get the.
Get the proportions of the figure right.
So a couple of things that you'll see
is that they'll use very round shapes overall.
So I'm not sure if that is indicative of just
the people living back then.
That they had just rounder forms in their faces
could be a thing,
but overall
the faces themselves
and sort of the
almost like
the shape language they were using
was very round,
very soft forms,
curvy, both in men and women, by the way.
Not like they made a lot of difference there,
it's just Very curvy forms.
And they really understood value really well.
And even line weight,
they like really understood where to emphasize line.
And one of the most obvious things
is that they had a really good understanding
of soft forms
versus hard edges.
And so they used cross hatching very effectively
to get that form across.
Knowing contour and form is so important, right?
That's why we teach it so much at Art Waters.
Like knowing the form of things
will help you understand it better.
And they also knew how to shadow map.
Like they knew how to add in shapes
that would replacingly
and better communicate the form.
But I'd say
if you wanna mimic this style,
then it's all about
understanding
how to work with soft form
and then cross hatching
to make that form pop.
But I'd say
form is the first thing you wanna master.
You know, in our beginner course
we explain this completely
on how to understand form.
From the basics
to more complicated form,
to form in the figure.
To really get a sense of how you can shade things.
Cause if you don't understand form,
you can't really shade it.
Cause you need to understand
and be aware of the form
in 3D space
in order to shade it more effectively.
And I think
one of the most noticeable things
that I see in this art style
is just the master's ability
to imply detail.
Not dried out completely,
just imply It.
They also really understood the concept of gradients
and separating the lights from the dark.
All of the things you need to know
to be an effective painter.
So start drawing first, right?
That's why we teach our students to
really own those fundamental drawing skills
and that spatial awareness first,
cause that's ultimately
what will lead you to become a better painter.
Their brush economy
with the hair, right.
They weren't drawing individual strands of hair,
they were drawing
and implying clusters of hair
and knowing where to
add a stroke
to indicate
the texture of hair,
but then leave everything else up to the.
Almost the imagination of the viewer.
Right. But it's.
It's literally
form of stylization.
They were already doing stylization.
If you wanna draw
in the style of Renaissance,
get ready to start learning your drapery.
Cause they were absolute masters of drapery.
The way they could imply
form and folding
is of course
they had a lot of reference at hand.
But again, just like with the hair,
they were able to stylize things a lot.
Do not be mistaken
at how well they were aware of folds
and drapery
and how they could
simplify it
and suggest
different types of folds.
They were well aware of
how to imply
these forms and details
very meticulously.
And that's something that takes a lot of practice,
a lot of knowledge,
and something like
if you wanna get good at this,
then you really need
To practice those.
Those skills.
And you don't necessarily need to do it on
an actual human body,
like you can do it on a mannequin.
It's what we do in our.
In our drapery course,
as we focus on
draping the folds
around a mannequin
so you understand the simple
structure underneath
and then can focus on
how these folds
would behave
based on the structure underneath.
Then you don't have to be
distracted by anatomy.
You can put that on top
later, I think,
after they sort of
laid in the initial form,
as I'm doing here,
and the values,
then you can go in
and finesse with
like some more
cross hatching
and increasing value
or adding more value.
Where you wanna push form,
where you wanna pull form.
Course, he also
had erasers,
probably to
pull out highlights
or fix mistakes.
Alright, so there you go.
That's about as far as I will take it.
In the next video,
we'll look at
how they paint it
in the Renaissance style.
But for now,
remember that
thing you really need to know is
again, your form
and how to indicate
the volume of form
and then drapery. Right.
Those are the
three major things
that really
are, you know,
very obvious
in this, well, style,
particularly
in just what they were focusing on
at the time.
So if you wanna
get a similar look
or you wanna.
You just study
a little bit of this,
cause it's Really good
for your development.
And, you know,
make sure that
you pay attention to these things.
And if you wanna know more about how to
increase your volume
understanding
and spatial awareness
and, you know,
rendering, form
and drapery,
then check out
the fantastic courses
that we have available
at artwat. Com.
Have fun, everyone.